[Music]
night for the final night of the
republican national convention
just moments away the opera singing you
just heard will give way to speeches and
then the president
we'll be carrying all of it here on fox
so stay tuned
so riots across the country for the last
three months raised the question
why do we have police well we hire cops
to clean up the messes the rest of us
create when people don't get
married before they have kids and their
fatherless sons turn violent
or when big business offshores
blue-collar jobs and entire communities
collapse
it is the police who deal with the
consequences not all cops are good at
their jobs
obviously but in the end the big
problems are not their fault most of
them are just working class guys doing
their best
unfortunately for them working class
guys are donald trump's
base and the democratic party hates them
for that particularly in an election
year
so to neutralize them the left is
constructed an absurd
a baseless but elaborate lie designed to
convince you that the police are the
real problem in this country
amazingly an awful lot of people have
fallen for it
that's why there are no cops around
anymore the result of that
chaos dozens dead kids in the streets
with guns america's cities on fire
why did that happen because the left
neutered the police
that's why it happened none of these
cities looked like this three months ago
not until they did this the consequences
are their fault
they're not your fault they're not the
fault of the police they're the fault of
the academic left that made this
possible across the country
kenosha wisconsin is the latest place
that's happened here's some of what
happened in that city this week
yes
[Music]
so who did that who turned a nice little
town like kenosha wisconsin
into a heliscape where 17 year olds are
shooting people
you didn't do that the cops didn't do
that the left
did that they destroyed that city
they embedded the violence you saw the
other night
period they made the cops go away and
when the cops left
lunacy filled the void period
they're denying that now but they're
lying as usual the media didn't even
want to cover it mostly they didn't
so the job of covering the riots fell to
people like julio rosas he's a senior
writer at town hall he was there
he joins us for an update on what's
happened in kenosha julio thanks so much
for coming on so what's the state of the
city tonight
so i i flew out of kenosha this uh this
morning and last night was was largely
peaceful there were still
uh gatherings past curfew and uh
but it was they had a march they marched
throughout the street but i didn't see
any confrontations between officers or
protesters or even armed civilians
as unfortunately we saw tuesday night
and so i think that was the result of
trump sending in more reinforcements and
because people seemingly are more scared
after the multiple shootings that
happened on tuesday
so from our perspective and talking to
others who were there
it looks like predictably violence
filled the void left by legitimate law
enforcement there was no one around to
keep order so
of course violence exploded was that
your impression being there
absolutely i mean this this could have
been stopped on monday night because
the writing broke out on sunday and
instead of
asking for the reinforcements necessary
the
the police and uh were mostly kept to
protect the county courthouse and
the precinct and so that left the the
rest of the downtown area at the mercy
of rioters and
multiple buildings were burned a lot of
property was damaged they particularly
were uh like to target uh parking lots
full filled with cars and so
uh and then we saw that again a little
bit on tuesday night and and
we and we saw and i was only a few feet
away from the side of the second
shooting
and it was just it was just chaos it was
absolutely anarchy and so
i mean this is really the result of poor
leadership at both the local and the
state level
of course it is it looks scary as hell
from the pictures was it
uh as you know tucker i've been
traveling all across the country in
minneapolis
seattle portland los angeles new york
and this was
uh second to minneapolis and the only
reason why minneapolis is still number
one in my book
is just because of how large scale it
was much a much much bigger scale but
but
kenosha of all places uh it turns out to
be
number two in my book in terms of just
absolute anarchy
of all places exactly thanks so much for
that i appreciate i'm glad you're safe
thank you